hello everyone my name is Jen Hoffman
and I'm the director of student
relations in cephas office of career
services and I thank you for joining us
today for the launch of our alumni
career development program we are
fortunate to have joining us Caroline
sanusi levine from six-figure start calm
and in just a few minutes I'll make a
proper introduction to Caroline first
let me spend a little bit of time
talking about the office of career
services and the resources that we offer
alumni lifetime access to programs
resources and advising there are many
resources on our website which include
fact sheets about professional
development from interviewing to resume
writing etc we'll get to that in a few
minutes as well as subscriptions to
databases including vault com wet feet
Devex calm for example vault is a leader
in providing industry guides and
employment information so by accessing
walls from our website not from the
general browser because you won't have
access through OCS a subscription but if
you access through our website you may
download guides that are valued at
between 10 and a hundred dollars at the
bookstore but they are free to you by
guys I mean things like industry guides
let's say an industry guide to
consulting you can download a guide to
the case interview so recommend going
through our website for volcom Devex is
a website for jobs in development and
what feed is another guy for job search
and Industry information if you haven't
already joined the LinkedIn people
alumni group consider doing so you'll
also find general sepa a general sepa
group on LinkedIn for alumni students
and professionals as well as the CEPA
energy and kiba Finance Group their
career fairs plan throughout the year
this Friday Columbia is hosting two
career fairs environment career fair and
a nonprofit career fair
OCS hosts many other career events
throughout the year one program includes
where's the your career series and this
is on CP link you can find out more
about that there are evening panels
throughout the semester generally our
alumni sit on those panels there are
other people other professionals as well
this week gender policy urban policy
foundation security and political risk
and programs run through the end of
March their concentration receptions
throughout the year there are held in
different locations in New York these
are great for networking purposes
catching up with your friends and are of
course vital to our current students
professional development in their
exposure to you our alumni each year in
January sepa heads down to DC as you may
know for the DC career conference during
this time hundreds of SIBO and alumni
see what alumni and students gather
together in a reception there are
employers site visits many of which are
arranged through our alumni and there is
a day of panels in which our alumni and
other career professionals in the DC
area speak to our current students this
is a terrific program very successful
and we'd enjoy having you involved in
any way you'd like as an attendee or as
a panelist maybe you can help us set up
site visits as well there are job
postings on sepa link they are not just
for current students we have mid-career
job postings as well as entry-level
postings and if your organization has
jobs to post please do let us know and
we will post those up on sip a link
there are workshops and as you know this
webinars for alumni and the Alumni
career advisory program or a cab is our
database to connect alums with current
students where our alums act as career
advisors for students if you're
interested in getting involved we would
very much appreciate it and you
contact me I want to give you a quick
peek at the breadth and scope of our
fact sheets on our website here is a
page from our career services role on my
website and if you scroll down you would
see fact sheets and here is a sample of
some of the fact sheets that we have
career changers your two-minute pitch
interviews etc and then there are
sector-specific fact sheets as well so
you can take a look at those finally as
many of you certainly know daniela
coleman is supposed director of alumni
affairs and she sends out a regular
newsletter to all sepa alums if you do
not receive this newsletter please
contact daniela and following this
webinar i will send her contact
information to you ok let me introduce
our presenter today Caroline sinisa
levine we're delighted that she's
joining us caroline is a former
recruiter who has hired thousands of
people for leading firms in banking
consulting media nonprofit pharma
biotech and technology she's a career
coach writer a speaker and co-founder of
six figures start and she has been an
adjunct assistant professor at sea
before ten years caroline is a graduate
of barnard college today she worked as a
career columnist for CNBC com and
forbes.com and is a co-author along with
Donald Trump Jack Canfield and other
leading business gurus of the
best-selling how the fierce handle fear
secrets to succeeding in challenging
times her career advice and job market
insights have been extensively quoted
including appearances on CBS and
mentions in Business Week Christian
Science Monitor CNNMoney nbcnews.com
Newsweek NPR the list goes on caroline
is a 2010 grant recipient of the jones
new york empowerment fund okay take it
away Caroline we are going to cover a
number of different things in the next i
would say 40 minutes i'm going to try to
leave at least ten if not 15 minutes for
questions we're going to talk about what
exactly do I mean by
hidden job market we're going to talk
about job search from the employers
perspective it's really really important
that you put yourself in the shoes of
the employer of the hiring manager of
the recruiter so that those strategies
and the tactics that you use are
actually going to elicit the response
that you want so we'll go behind the
scenes in the hiring process and talk
about that we are going to talk about
job search from the candidates
perspective because there are things
that you will need to be doing to be
effective in your job search that are
obviously very different from what the
employer is doing on their side then
we'll talk specifically about finding
the decision-makers i'm going to be
talking about that a lot this this issue
of going directly to the decision makers
as opposed to the recruiter and so
obviously I'm going to go in more detail
about how exactly to do that how to find
them and then how to engage them and
follow up with them and then finally
I'll end with a checklist of lessons
learned so that hopefully this isn't
just theoretical and that you can move
forward and actually act on this advice
so in terms of the introduction again
Jennifer did a super job with that the
only thing that I would want to mention
and just highlight is that you know this
is coming from a recruiters perspective
so between my partner Connie dinosaurs
and myself we have hired thousands of
people we have seen just a number of
different careers and different chubster
strategies and we know from having hired
people and from working with other
recruiters who are hiring people you
know what it takes to be successful I
personally and I put my picture there so
we can feel like we're all in a room
together and you know who's you can
attach a face to a name but I personally
have changed careers many many times I
was actually a music major when I was at
Barnard of his music and economics and I
competed and I played on classical piano
and then I I switched careers and I
became a management consultant so before
I was a recruiter I was on the line as a
management consultant in investment
banking and risk management and then I
moved into retained executive search and
then I went back to the
arts I actually left corporate for a
couple of years to do acting and then I
went back into corporate I was in
corporate HR this time and I ran several
recruiting areas for Time Inc including
university relations which was all of
their entry-level hiring and internship
hiring and then I sound co-founded
six-figure start with Connie so I've
been in the arts and business arts and
business I've been in big companies i've
been in small companies i've started my
own company i totally believe that your
own internal readiness to work hard and
to pursue the job in the career that you
want is more important than what market
conditions might dictate so i really
believe that if you follow a proactive
approach and strategy to your job search
that you will get the results on meaning
that you will get hired in the job that
you want and so it is all up to you that
is all I will say about that let's talk
about the hidden job market so what do I
mean by the hidden job market I mean the
jobs that are not widely posted or
marketed and by some accounts so the
five o'clock club which is a 25 year old
national outplacement and career
coaching firm and I have done some work
with them and they really track you know
their job seekers eighty percent their
data is showing eighty percent of jobs
are filled not five postings or by
recruiters but by networking and direct
contact with the decision-makers so by
that statistic eighty percent represents
the hidden job market I can tell you
that when I was recruiting on behalf of
companies as an external recruiter or
when I was inside of Time Inc and and
recruiting exclusively for them I can
say that employee referrals and and take
people already inside our candidate
database accounted for a very very high
percentage i would put that at about
sixty five seventy percent of jobs that
were filled and i have to tell you from
a recruiters perspective there's nothing
nefarious about this so the hidden job
market is not
about hiring you know our BFS and our
close family members in fact in a lot of
cases on the people who were referred
were not again necessarily someone's
best friend it was just someone who was
in that person's network and they felt
that this person would be a good fit for
the firm and they put that person
forward and the reason why that work in
terms of getting referred in terms of
getting to these jobs early the reason
why it works is because I'm thinking as
a recruiter that my best employees you
know know what it takes to be successful
at the company and so that's that's what
so there's already a self-selection
going on I feel like okay this person
got referred I'm going to take a longer
look at them the other reason is this
just out of courtesy right someone is
working with me they're my colleague
they want me to take a look at someone I
am absolutely more likely to take a look
at them then I would an unsolicited
resume that crosses my desk or a resume
that's sitting in the thousands of
resumes in the company website so you
can imagine that a fortune 500 like Time
Warner would have just you know
thousands and thousands of resumes and
even the best candidate databases
there's a limit to how well you can
search them so things would definitely
fall through the cracks so that's
another reason why you absolutely want
to have that personal contact and that's
really what I'm going to be focusing on
so let's talk about the job search from
the employer's perspective and it has
eight steps okay so the first step is
that the opening is to find the budget
is approved is the second step the
search ticks off resumes or screens
interviews are conducted finalists are
selected the offer is extended and
negotiated and finally the new hire is
on boarded so I wanted to highlight a
few things from this you can see and the
reason why I had bolded the first three
steps the opening is defined meaning
that someone in the company
typically the boss of the person that is
going to be taking the jobs of the boss
realizes that they haven't needed so it
could be the head of public relations
needs another PR manager it could be
that the fashion editor needs someone on
her team it could be that the finance
director needs an additional tax person
or additional internal audit person or
whatever right so so someone has has
determined that a need exists that's the
first step the second step is then the
need actually becomes approved because
just the fact that someone determines
hey it would be great to have another PR
manager on our team you know doesn't
meet doesn't make it so right so the
whoever it is the head of PR and that
that example you know maybe they have
that budget approval or maybe it has to
go up a notch maybe they're say a chief
you know administrative officer or you
know depending on how a company in
structured maybe there's somebody else
who has to backstop that and say yes we
are absolutely going to put budget
against this position so just because
the need is identified doesn't mean that
it's going to result into a job the
budget needs to be approved that's step
two but notice that both of these steps
are happening internally to the company
so before a job is even public there's
stuff going on in the in the back end
and so if people had net worked their
way to the head of PR in this example or
to the chief admin officer in this
example and represented themselves as an
amazing PR manager you can bet that that
person is going to be front of minds as
this searches kicking off and sometimes
if that person is exactly what they're
looking for they're not even going to
launch a search why would they do I have
definitely seen and clients that I've
worked with where you know an opening
gets defined you know they think that
they're going to watch a search and then
they say you know what I actually have
someone in mind or I actually met
someone a few months ago I think would
be perfect let me check and see if if
they're still available let me talk to
this person they may never launch a
formal search now they may
do that and still launch a formal search
but that person that they had in mind
has obviously a head start they're
already front of mind for the people
making the decision so you can see that
to get into a search in those first two
steps is really really important the
third step is also really important for
you to know which means that the search
kicks off meaning that I hear from the
head of PR that we need another PR
manager right and at that point I can
then decide if I'm an internal recruiter
like I was when I was at timing I can
then decide ok we're going to post this
we're probably on our company website
but then also potentially on different
job boards like mediabistro or maybe
something more general like a monster or
I'm going to work with an external
recruiter attending normally didn't do
that but other companies do have
external recruiters so that's something
I feel like I need to mention for you
guys so I might put it out there for an
external recruiter or I might put it out
there for someone on my team I might say
okay you've got some bandwidth you're
going to work on this particular search
or I'm going to get my PR specialist
recruiter to work on this search so
there are a number of different things
that we might be doing or I myself might
work on the first or I myself might have
candidates in mind I just talked to a
great PR person that this magazine can
use but maybe this new magazine that's
looking for someone maybe they can use
them so you can see that the search can
kick off in a number of different ways
this is before even I've decided to dive
into a pile of resumes there are things
that are happening so there's a lot of
time that has elapsed and we've
determined that there's a need and this
is where the hidden job market gets
created and if you can get in to this
sweet spot of the first kind of three
steps if you can be at the decision
maker at the head of PR you know
networking yourself as a great PR
manager on that obviously is going to
help you leapfrog over a lot of
candidates who are really really focused
on the resume sending a number of
different resumes out for jobs again
that might already be filled so you can
see that it's not until step for that
we're screening resumes
candidates for interviews etc etc etc
okay so there are a number of I put
these other steps there what I will
mention is notice that step 8 is not the
offer as a you know is accepted it's the
person is actually in the building the
search does not stop until the person is
in the building I have definitely
experienced and many of my experience
recruiting colleagues have experienced
people you know welcome to go to webinar
web events made easy oh that it is not
over until that person is in the dull
day so we are always keeping in touch
with great candidates that we've met
along the way we will continue to keep
in touch with great candidates even
after the position of films because
again we don't know how well this person
is going to do or if there's another
search around the corner that's going to
be similar from this okay so it's
something to remember on something that
I'm going to go back to when I talk
about engagement and follow up is that
remember that when you are working with
a prospective employer recruiter near
the hiring manager it's not just about
that job it is about establishing a
relationship because you want you can
see that this is a circular thing the
new hire is on-boarded sure but we're
going to be working on other searches
we're opening is to find the budget is
approved etc etc etc so you want to
maintain a relationship that is ongoing
ok so the highlights here searches do
not begin in HR unless you are an HR
executive or recruiter a calm person a
benefits person a generalist etcetra you
know the search is not going to begin an
HR it's going to begin in PR and finance
or an editorial or you know the other
examples that I had given okay unless
the salary is covered by HR that step to
the budget being approved that's also
going to happen elsewhere now there are
some instances where HR has say a
general management training program or
some other centralized budget that we're
overseeing and in that case the budget
approval you know might come into my
hands or into you know another one of
the
the HR folks but for the most part again
it's residing somewhere in and around
that actual hiring area and therefore
your chances of accessing the hidden job
market of getting to that eighty percent
of jobs that are not wildly posted or
advertised your chances are improved if
you have access to the actual hiring
department and not h are so many
candidates that I've met you know
jobseekers that I've met are so
concerned about getting in front of
recruiters about meeting people in HR
and I absolutely think that you should
if you have relationships with
recruiters definitely cultivate that
it's very useful and obviously I'm
involved in the process of hiring people
but it is not a substitute and in fact
if I had to choose where I would spend
my time I would absolutely be focused on
the actual hiring department you need to
network and you need to know people and
the structure and the thought process
and the challenges that are being faced
at the line of business level not at the
HR level at the line of business level
okay so remember what I had said about
when the search kicks off I said that we
might kick it off in a variety of ways
including posting on the website posting
on an external website classified ads
employee referrals external recruiters
employee referral always takes the bulk
of hiring this is especially true when
the market is ticking upward as it is
now I can definitely tell you that the
market is a lot the job market is a lot
busier we are by no means at the boom
boom time where you know jobseekers get
essentially hopped from job to job with
abandon it is still I would say as a
buyers market it's still the employers
market that being said there are a lot
more job posting flying around that I've
heard from my recruiting college they
are very very busy and it's really
difficult for them to stay on top of all
of this new hiring and when this is
happening is you can imagine that
companies have kind of cut to the bone
and that includes
the recruiting staff now they're busy
really busy hiring again it's going to
take a while for them to catch up to all
of this new volume there's going to be a
lot of noise in there so to the extent
that you can come in there and really
again network with the right people who
are going to be doing the hiring that's
really really helpful in a market like
this one I worked recently with a
nonprofit that was hiring was growing
they were hiring like gangbusters and
they were so busy and they were in the
throes of building out their recruiting
function that was why I was called in to
build up their recruiting function so
they really didn't have a base from
which to work and so really you know yes
we did all the things like posting and I
you know reorganized how they were going
to do that going forward but in terms of
what was happening right now triage and
the ER we needed to get some really
qualified bodies in those positions and
I have to say I we really leaned on the
employees of the existing organization
to work their networks and to find
people who were already somehow
pre-qualified and I also looked very
closely at people who would write in and
would network specifically say with me
or someone on the recruiting team or
someone else on on the corporate team
because I felt like okay this person has
made an effort to really get in there
and get to know me they clearly know
this space that also is much more of a
soft selection than someone just stayed
dropping a resume was clearly a generic
cover letter or just responding to a
post day those things are much more
passive it's much more impressive if you
can really Network your way in so really
keep that in mind especially as the
market is ticking upward okay but let's
talk about what you need to be doing
tactically right because you are not
approving budget or you're not you know
screening resumes so there's something
so while that is going on and you need
to recognize that that is going on so
you can position yourself accordingly
you also need to be doing certain things
for your job search six-figure start we
use a six step approach to the job
search number one is to identify your
target
and I'm going to talk more about that
but it means function industry and
geography a well defined target is
critical to this approach of identifying
the decision makers to is create your
marketing campaign notice how I didn't
say resume your marketing campaign is
more than your resume its resume and
cover letter online profile networking
pitch it is everything that represents
you when you are not there to represent
yourself so that also includes your
email signature your voicemail message
that is all part of your marketing
campaign step three is research so when
I'm talking about finding these
decision-makers and knowing how to
engage them you're going to do that by
exhaustive and in-depth research using
sites like fall like Jennifer mentions
and all of the it sounds like great
great resources through career services
at ciba step four is networking and
interviewing and that is one in the same
a job interview is a subset of a
networking interaction okay you could be
interviewing some remember that very
very first point that I made that the
end of the search is when someone gets
on board it is not when someone accepts
the job there are so many things that
can happen in the course of a search
I'll talk about that a little bit later
on but just remember that when you
interview for a specific job it is
really about developing a networking
relationship not just about that job
step 5 is to stay motivated and
organized and troubleshoot your job
search so just because you're meeting
with a lot of people doesn't mean that
your search is moving forward at the end
of the day are you meeting with the
decision makers and I'm talking about
are you a PR person I'm manager-level
person that then needs to be approved
and hired by the head of that group well
then you need to be meeting with the
head of that group and not other PR
managers which would be interesting
networking meetings to have in terms of
informational research but they are not
going to get you hired so at some points
in your search you really have to be
looking back at your efforts and saying
am i meeting the right people and I see
this at all levels i worked at someone
recently who
very in a senior guy and so senior that
he really needs to be talking to see
sweet or very very senior executives in
terms of the people who are going to
make the hiring decision for him about
him and the problem was that he was
interacting with a lot of other VP level
people which was great informational II
for the first 2-3 weeks but he really
needed to move on and get to the
decision makers so step 5 is a reminder
that you need to look at your search and
make sure that you're doing that step 6
is to negotiate and close the offer so
notice in the six steps there's not a
mention of a resume there okay many
candidates spend way too much time
worrying about the resume there is no
separate resume step in the above
process because it is not as important
as candidates sink you obviously can't
have a resume that misrepresents you or
doesn't represent you well that's
riddled with typos and errors they know
so that's just job search 101 right so
I'm expecting that all of you guys being
you know add a top you know graduates at
the top level you know masters program
have you know that resume 101 but what
I'm talking about is to get your job
search to the next level where you can
cut through the noise of this volatile
busy yet improving market you know you
really need to focus on a strategic and
proactive campaign okay so step one was
identify your target right and I said
industry plus function plus geography
Financial Services is not a target okay
financial services is an industry you
could be in HR and financial services as
I was at one point right you can be an
HR you can be in marketing you can be in
sale you can be in finance you can be a
lot of things in financial services
without a functional area it's
meaningless you can be in New York you
can be in San Francisco you can be in
Mumbai without a geography it's also
meaningless because if you told me that
you wanted to have an HR you know
executive role within a financial
services firm
and your scope of the search was limited
to Topeka Kansas yeah that's absolutely
still doable there are retail banks that
are out there there are insurance firms
I'm sure that are out there it's dr. etc
but you know if you're if you're looking
to work at a goldman sachs you know that
obviously your geography is misaligned
with what your your long-term
aspirations are so industry press
function plus geography until you have
clarity on those three things it can be
very very difficult for you to identify
these decision makers because once you
have that intersection you can then find
out who the key players are you can go
to the Chamber of Commerce in Topeka
Kansas and you can find out who all the
players are in specifically financial
services you can find out how big they
are so that you can see okay how big of
an HR department it going to have can
they absorb someone like me I don't know
what your HR skill set is of course
there's a hypothetical example right so
you can start looking at things like
five so until you have that three
element intersection to find it's very
difficult than to find your key players
then you'll have to know how they're
structured so remember in the very
beginning the example of the PR manager
so you know I kind of threw that out
pretty loosely so I could have been
talking about p on our for a specific
magazine let's say that I was still
talking about my work at time inc where
you know they're 140 magazines at the
time that i was there right so maybe it
was it is PR for magazine or to make
this more general PR for a specific line
of business or maybe its corporate
communications as a whole maybe there's
you know a corporate-wide PR group and
maybe PR for each one of business roles
into the corporate ypr i don't know but
you need to know this for your targets
because when you try to find the
decision-makers you essentially need an
org chart so that you can find who is
going to be at the levels that are above
you that's going to be making these
types of hiring decisions so that's what
you're driving towards who manages the
group and/or position that you are
targeting I'm telling you know that it's
going to be obviously very difficult for
you to network and find that person
because you can't even
articulate what it is that you're
looking for I just got off the phone
coaching someone who has a very very
well-defined intersection in this case
education and specifically alternative
education she's really looking at the
cutting edge of what's happening she's
looking at everything from foundations
like the Gates Foundation to stay like
the charter school organization which is
trying to do something different and say
you know the public school the existing
public school system so so her her niche
is pretty tight and she was looking at
she'd identified some key players and
she actually even identified a role and
so she comes through with this role and
I said to her so who did that role
report into because she actually knew
someone at that organization and she
said oh I have no idea now that's where
she needs to go right she was very
content finding some when she knew in
that organization and that's a great
start but like I said in terms of
driving your search towards people who
can actually help you get higher or
higher you directly you absolutely need
to know who is hiring for the positions
that you're going for so yes it will be
helpful to do informational interviews
for the organization as a whole and I
encouraged her to keep her contact with
her friend but she very quickly has to
find out who's going to be managing that
open position that she wants because
that is the person that she needs to get
to and that is who you need to get you
for your search so you need to be very
very clear for everybody that you are
targeting you know where does your
position reside as you know another
example of private sector example I had
a client who was in technology and who
had worked in product development in
technology so of course we wanted to
know who what geography is he going to
focus on specifically you know what type
of technology cuz he was in medical
equipment but also had done some
information technology so was he going
to go kind of the medical equipment
biotech/pharmaceuticals out or was he
going to focus more than knowledge
management issues the IT issues and
therefore try to go for us an oracle or
you know so you can and he can do both
but but the point is is that each way
that he go is he
needs to then pick who the key players
are you need to see how they're
structured and how they're structured in
terms of product development is is it by
line of business is it by the actual
product is it by geography those that's
very very important to know that because
he really needs to be able to navigate
his way into these giant firms I mean
for something like Oracle that's huge
I'm sure they have product development
just all over the place and they
probably have a matrix type of
organization where it's both developing
products within a specific line of
business or customer demographic as well
as within a specific geography but then
it's really really important to tease
out ok so what takes priority and as I
am looking for openings and as I am
trying to network with people based on
his backgrounds and the skill set that
he brought to the table where does it
make sense for him to actually try to
position himself so this is why you
really need to know who you are
targeting research was another step
right in the six-step job search process
so why do I harp on research it's
because you need to know what's going on
with your targets so that you can
actually engage them this is kind of
feeding into the how do you engage the
decision-makers you find you find them
by knowingly your targets are you engage
them by talking about their business in
a way that shows you as an insider make
sure that you show don't tell right i
have so many people were say I'm
hard-working I'm a quick learner I'm
enthusiastic you will not say that they
are all of those things I want you to
show me that in specific examples of
work that you've done okay so really
beware of instances where you've had to
say trust me I can learn that or i can
change right i can change in terms of oh
yeah sure I've never done marketing I'm
a sales person but I can do that I can
make that career change no no no no no
ok thats that's not good enough i can
hire people who have already done
marketing right so you need to be doing
that either in pro bono consulting that
you're
on the side in volunteer work or you
need to grow your job exactly where you
are so that you can start incorporating
some new skills and experience and have
something to show me instead of just
telling me I always make the analogy of
you know a boyfriend right an old
boyfriend or girlfriend who comes to you
and says trust me I'll change right
that's exactly the type of reaction that
I will have for a candidate that has no
or little experience in the job that I'm
recruiting for that will tell me you
know I'm a quick learner or you know I
can I can transfer my skills that's just
not good enough you need the research as
well to make informational interviews
two-way conversation okay so yes
informational interviewing 101 is about
collecting information about a day and
the wife of you know the person that
you're interviewing and when I teach
professional development at sepa you
know there's a great guide actually I
don't know if the super guidebook
Jennifer you'll have to to post this if
it's available to people who have
already graduated if you haven't kept a
copy of yours but the the professional
development text has you know list of
information or any questions and these
are you know these are good questions
have a conversation with but I've always
told my students you know you should
also be trying to answer these questions
yourself through secondary research you
should have an idea of what the typical
or expected answer should be so that you
can go a step further with the person
that you're interviewing and really ask
them about things that you can't find
from secondary research and and really
get to the nuances of things it also
enables you to demonstrate that you're
an insider that you have this knowledge
it's much more engaging and interesting
for the person that you are interviewing
with at the end of the day the bonus
question is do you know what keeps your
targets up at night do you know what
worries the head of PR or the finance
director so that when you do position
yourself when you do talk to people you
can highlight how you can absolutely be
the solution to their problems
how do you follow up with decision
makers let's say that you identify your
target you know who these people are
you've been able to get that first
interview with them that informational
interviews knock their socks off with
your in-depth research you've engaged
them there isn't anything open you'd
like to stay on their radar you'd like
to do that without being a pest of
course keep in mind that the best
follow-up is generous and under no
obligation it is non-committal right so
so the best follow-up so first of all
every contact is a mini interview okay
every time you pick up the phone and
you're talking to someone even if it is
to schedule the meeting that's an
interview because that shows your poise
your professionalism your presentation
your communication your work ethic your
motivation obviously depending on how
quickly your response time is and it
shows your expertise and credibility
because if I'm starting to engage you
may be a little bit in small talk and
you're incredibly inarticulate or you're
not up on on what's going on you know
that'll give me second thoughts about
scheduling you I might still scheduled
you and I think okay this is an off day
but that's definitely already in my mind
so you've already have a
come-from-behind situation so keep in
mind that every single contact that you
make no matter how small that is a
chance to assess you and every little
contact you make focus on building the
long-term relationship not just getting
the job you know at that point in time
it's like i said before people will
renege at the last minute hires will
work out maybe they find out that they
need two people instead of one there are
many many reasons why a search that
seemingly is closed or no longer
available becomes available and so you
definitely want to make sure that you
stay friend of mine now what do i mean
by you know non-committal what i mean is
you know don't make every single
interaction about your job search make
sure that when you are talking to people
you are sharing something based on what
their interests are if you had this
terrific informational interview and now
you know more things about them you
should then be able to know okay
their interest this is what's keeping
them up night this is what they're
interested in I can you send them
articles about that i can make
recommendations based on that as i go
through other informational interviews
and learn information i can share that
with them obviously on a confidential
basis but this shows that you are
generous and that you are aware of
what's going on and you're willing to
share that with them so think about
really think about what else can you
talk about besides your job now
absolutely especially if you're in a
formal interview situation it is
absolutely ok to check in and say you
know what's the time to you know where
where are you in the search I just
wanted to find out if you needed any
more information about me that's
absolutely fine to do you know on a
regular but not too frequent basis but
in between that you do want to have
other points of context because again it
just keeps you front of mind without
being a pest now remember that the
interview process will always end later
than you think okay you don't know when
you're meeting with them even if they
say it's the final round it's not
necessarily the final round it could
turn out that you have to meet
additional people so you really want in
a formal interview situation on to find
out three things okay what is the
interview process in the decision time
table it bothers me to no end when I
hear about candidates not knowing you
know they leave an interview and they
don't have agreement the person as they
spoke to in terms of when they're
supposed to hear back you're absolutely
entitled to find that out they might not
be able to say on the button in terms of
this particular day but you know you
might find out that the person is taking
a two-week vacation and if you call them
three times in that two weeks you're
just being a pest so really find out the
the process and decision timetable find
out how your targets are defining
success for me i call this get the real
job description okay job descriptions
are notoriously inaccurate so when
you're in an interview situation you
want to just to make sure that you you
have them to find you know what will
success look like 30 days 60 days 90
days 120 days 365 days out so you know
exactly
you know what is going to be expected of
you and you know how to follow up
effectively so that you hit on the
points that they obviously care about
and then finally you don't want to leave
an interview without knowing you know
why your targets want you as a pop as
opposed to not wanting you okay so what
made them decide to call you in for an
interview and then what do they still
have hesitations about okay so this way
you can position yourself correctly and
remember and I put this in italics you
know you might be the second choice they
might have extended an offer but you
might be a very very very close second I
have had so many situations where we've
had to go to the close second because
either the first trace turned us down or
something happened during the auction
ago she ation we realized that this
wasn't going to be the right person or
the jobs that change and all of them the
second choice becomes the first choice
there are many many reasons why you
don't have to necessarily come out on
top to make things still worth your
while so just to make sure that you are
developing relationships throughout the
way okay so I'm just going to wrap up
and make sure that because I can see
already questions swimming it I want to
leave time for that are you getting to
prospective employers before the search
kicked off so are you getting to those
decision-makers when an opening is
defined and when the budget is being
approved that means getting out of HR
and into the actual line of business are
you staying front of mind throughout all
the steps you have a six-step job search
process the employer has eight steps in
their process they're looking at resumes
are looking at inner they're
interviewing people they're calling
people that this is all happening times
however many jobs were hiring for so you
can imagine that you know what seems
like one process to you for us is x 10
or x 20 or x 50 or x 100 i had when i
was building out that recruiting
function for the nonprofit we had a
hundred open jaws and they all needed to
be filled by a specific date because of
the kids because of a very strict you
know academic calendar a hundred jobs so
it was like triage in the ER so
we've got other things on our mind so
you need to stay front of mine through
generous and non-committal follow-up do
you focus on relationships okay so
remember relationship not just about
getting any one specific job you need
relationships to get to searches early
right to get to that sweet spot of where
the opening is defined in the budget is
being approved you want to focus on
relationships so that your competitive
throughout all of the interview phases
so that even though you might be towards
the end of your interview I may just be
starting interviewing other candidates
and so the process is going to drag out
but you want to still maintain your
relationship with me and with the hiring
department so that you can stay front of
mind obviously negotiation and
onboarding you need relationships as
well do you have enough information so
look at your search to date and you know
I said to you exhaustive in-depth
research do you have your industry
function and geography defined do you
have the key players do you know how
they're structured so that you can
actually identify who these
decision-makers are so that you can
actually engage them on things that they
care about so that you can position
yourself well during interviews so that
you can negotiate well and so that you
can actually do a good job so I think
Jennifer is going to be passing out this
presentation so you will know how you
can stay in touch with us we post a lot
of free advice articles a lot of the
things that I've said on this call have
been printed in our blog and in our free
newsletter I have a number of different
social media groups on that I post
articles to not just my own but business
and career management articles that I've
seen just this morning I posted
something about boomers and just a new
entrepreneurial boom amongst that age
demographic we have a radio show every
first three tuesdays of the month at
12pm on blogtalkradio you can find that
on our website we've got pre-recorded
workshops and other you know different
events so for example when I'm working
with the bar nerd Club of Connecticut
and they're doing an event and it's at
the library's it's free and Westport
people of the Connecticut area can you
know can go see that that's also posted
on our website so just there are a lot
of things that are there for you to
continue your search and now I'm going
to take some of these questions which
are written so tiny um okay let me just
try to go back to the beginning so i can
take them in order okay i was let though
a year ago and did some consulting last
year are there any techniques to
overcome the negative impression of
being out of the job market for that
length of time oh i just did a blog post
on this I think was for CNBC it is on on
our website if i think of it i will i
will try to send a link to Jennifer to
the exact post but here's what I said
the reason why employers are wary of
people who are out of the market for an
extended period of time well there's one
reason the superficial reason is okay
why isn't this person higher now given
how bad the market has been I think
there's a little bit less of that but
there's still the sense of okay you know
why couldn't this person complete their
job search in a year so there's going to
be a little bit of that I used to get
over but if you're a strong candidate
otherwise you'll get over that pretty
quick the other things you know that I
would really worried about our how
current is your expertise how current is
your skill set and how current is your
network okay so expertise meaning a lot
of things can happen in a year okay so
depending on what type of work that you
do which you didn't say you know
regulatory changes could have happened
industry consolidation or restructuring
could have happened so there's this
issue of you know are you really far
behind the curve in terms of skill sets
you know just in terms of you know
things that have been happening in
social media or things that have been
happening you know if you look at any
really fast moving industry people are
going going to worry about that and then
in terms of your network a lot of the
reason why employers like the hire
people have been employed it's because
they already have this ready network
especially for jobs in sales that any
kind of
knowledge job in particular you know we
want to feel like okay you're really up
on who the competitors are you've been
in and around this industry all of that
on network is fresh so that's really
what the concern is about hiring someone
who who has been out of work and so you
can absolutely get over all of those
hurdles without having a job the fact
that you've been doing consulting is a
big deal so if you can highlight you
know again knowing what the trends and
the challenges are you know knowing
about the competitors and the key
players you can definitely overcome that
hurdle but just recognize that's what
we're going to be looking for we want to
make sure that you are current in your
expertise skills and network can you
give guidance on how to introduce
yourself to a decision maker who is not
on the front line of the job search and
was purposely put distance which in
himself herself and the candidates okay
great great question right so this is
why they get recruiters because they
don't want to have to deal with that so
okay just as you give you a nuanced
answer right because this is this a
great question and this is you know an
individual case-by-case thing it is true
that decision makers you know will
outsource to recruiters and will say you
deal with it and you find the people and
they don't want then to have unsolicited
people come to them but what I'm talking
about in terms of directly contacting
the decision-makers is not contacting
them necessarily about that job right
away but really engaging them in saying
you you know your department is trying
to do this I have done that or I know
the solution to that to give you a very
concrete example at a client who wanted
to break into healthcare finance she had
been in and around economics but not
specifically healthcare she wrote to
she's very very tight niche because this
this approach only works if you can
really really specify and her first
choice target were hospital she had a
very tight geography she listed out the
largest hospitals because of what
specific what she wanted to do with in
finance and she then was able to find
out who the head of finance was for
these hospitals now keep in mind that
he was not that senior so that's going
to be way too high a target but she
contacted these people by direct mail by
snail mail because she couldn't get
their email addresses and and phone was
you know she wasn't going to just call
the cold call them out of blue she sent
some letters and she told them about
their business she talked about health
care find out she talked about the
things that she wanted to do she got
meetings with so many people that way
oftentimes it wasn't with the head of
finance they pawned her off to someone
you know more junior but still more
senior to her and someone who's still
going to be a decision-maker in some way
shape or form and then about four weeks
into her doing that had already been
talking to a lot of people one of the
earliest informational interviews
actually contact her and did hey you
know we've got this opening that's
coming up and i just want to know if you
wanted to submit your resume before we
post it so this is you know clapping
example the hinge on market so so what I
would tell you is is that yes it is true
that sometimes if you go to a very
senior person they're going to say you
know what I'm going to put my I'm going
to just forward your resume to HR that
is not what you want right you really
want to try to speak to them about their
business or talk to someone who is
within that department about the
business because going to HR too early
in the process makes it all about a
specific job and not about really
finding out about the business what is
the best way to cold call or email
someone for an informational interview
how do you best make it clear they're
interesting opportunities without
sounding too eager or putting the person
on the spot yes you absolutely don't
want to make any reference to
opportunities we're going to assume that
why else are you really contacting us
really what you know like i said in the
healthcare example you really want to
make the person feel like they would
also benefit by speaking with you this
is where the research comes in you
really need a hook in terms of
understanding what problem they're
facing in our business and again how you
might be able to solve it for them this
is really you know the tricky tricky
part of the search for certain
industries like VC
you know I've had clients you have to do
that in three sentences plus some
presents who are they why are they
contacting this particular person and
why should this person speak to them you
really have to get it down to three
sentences for VC and really for a lot of
other places because your email needs to
be short but it is going to hinge on
you're trying to solve a problem for
them you want to talk to them you are
doing research in and around this
problem and talking to them it's the
next logical step amongst other things
that you're doing so you are talking to
other people as well that's really kind
of the root of it and in terms of you
know the specifics and how your
positioning yourself and what you want
is are you talking about you know that
needs to be customized obviously to you
know what you're you're targeting um you
mentioned making sure that you know why
you have been picked to interview as
well as what reservations company might
have about you how do you ask this
during the meeting you ask you ask at
the end of it certainly so that why did
they pick you that's an easy question to
ask you know in the beginning of it so
I'm just curious or is very helpful for
me to know what specifically about my
background attracted you to call me in
and then in terms of you know
hesitations you can ask point blank at
the end is there anything else I can
tell you about my background is there
anything about my background that gives
you any hesitations about me continuing
in this process or me doing this job and
you can count even if they don't want to
tell you can tell by the look on their
face if they have reservations and then
you'll have to try to figure it out if
they're for whatever reason not going to
be candid and tell you but some people
most people will say you know we're
looking at other candidate to have more
x experience or who have whatever what
methods resources can when used to
identify see players within an industry
function geography how does one find out
their internal structures groups and
managers so great question you can look
at so there might be some internal
information I'm sorry might be some
public information in things like volcom
in places that show you you know
different companies right and we'll
we'll walk through the different
departments of the different company
so you know for example I know that
vault has different newsletter is
dedicated to finance and consulting an
HR those are the three that I guess that
those ones I know about I'm sure there
are more you can also look at linkedin
linkedin is great so you can do a
linkedin search for a company to look at
what their titles look like you can look
at who on this doing these jobs and
again you know you are going to have to
do some informational interviewing are
people outside of that department just
to see how things are structured you can
even ask people who are not in that
specific department I mean that's the
company but in that industry in general
to say you know I'm trying to do some
research into time it can let's give it
your talk to someone at Conde Nast and
you can say you know are you structured
in if so are all the publishing company
structured in a similar way and you can
kind of get at it that way trade
associations are professional
associations are a great way of getting
data as well let's see oh my goodness
there's so many different questions
Jennifer I don't know I think we're
going to write a time for questions but
I will try why don't you and I talked
about the number of questions offline
after the webinar and we can figure out
how to handle them because you do have
many more that are continuing to come
through that I haven't sent to you yet
yeah so I mean they're just you know
there's y vente know this is really
really great that you know that people
have stayed on and you know and what I
would say is I'm going to see if I can
copy and paste the questions that have
streamed in already just I always keep a
list of questions and I try to use the
questions in my blog post and also on
the radio show we always leave time for
questions so that's another outlet of
them being answered but Jennifer do you
want to jump in for long yeah terrific
thank you so much Caroline this was a
wonderful launch to our alumni career
development webinar program and as
Caroline mentioned earlier she's offered
to share her slides with today's
attendees they'll also be information
about how to listen to Caroline on the
radio there's information about her blog
so some of your questions may be
answered there I'll also send my
introduction slides to you as well and
information about where you can purchase
the professional development guide that
Caroline mentioned also during her
program thanks to all of you for joining
us today we'll be sending you a survey
this afternoon and appreciate any
feedback you can give to us again
Caroline thank you so much for joining
us and everybody have a wonderful
afternoon bye-bye now